this morning nature's 10 million year
experiment to make the perfect sense
if you ask rowan jacobson what that
scent is it's the truffle his new book
truffle hound is a fascinating look at
how humans grow hunt and crave this
unique food truffles have long been
grown almost entirely in europe and
served almost exclusively in high-end
restaurants
both those things are changing as north
americans have made big advances growing
truffles and they become more accessible
to the home cook
to find out how the ground beneath us is
shifting
we went in search
of the elusive truffle
[Music]
every day in often secret locations
around the globe highly trained dogs
head into the woods on the hunts for
buried treasure feeding a growing market
worth billions of dollars
what they find if you're lucky can push
already gourmet dishes
into gastronomic kevin
what is it about truffles
you know i've spent the past two years
trying to figure that out rowan
jacobson's quest to unlock the mystery
of the truffle took him across the
atlantic and back four times as well as
nine states in canada his new book is
truffle hound on the trail of the
world's most seductive scent with
dreamers schemers and some extraordinary
dogs it's the strongest smell in the
world
right in front of you and then suddenly
it's gone it's so volatile so it's like
this intense memory is has already
passed by the time you've realized it
truffles are the fruiting body of a kind
of fungus that grow on or near tree
roots they've been harvested for tens of
thousands of years originally with pigs
and eventually once they discovered they
were less likely to eat the truffles
dogs they weren't truly cultivated and
enjoyed on mass until a couple hundred
years ago in europe
why the long obsession
simple
it's in our dna
smells really interesting it's the one
of our five senses that kind of skips
the higher consciousness part of the
brain entirely and goes straight to
where memory and emotions are processed
smell is the original sense back to when
we were single-celled organisms exactly
before we developed the other other
senses smell was everything to us let's
go okay yeah we may love the smell of
truffles while eating but humans are not
sophisticated enough to sniff them out
underground
that's why you need the dog
oh he got it
one hunting team jacobson writes about
are jerome curion and tofu look at this
one tastes very very good oh nice
nice wow
look at that puppy
okay tofu
kirian's farm two hours outside montreal
canada is one of only two in the world
currently growing a kind of truffle
potentially poised to change the
industry oh yeah he got it
they are appalachian truffles wow okay
let's try again tofu
it's amazing it's you can't even it's i
said it's gross but great it's amazing i
mean there's nothing like it these trees
were planted when
uh in 2010 so these are 12 years old
yeah truffles have always been in the
wild
farming them has been the challenge
it is a long-term never guaranteed
investment
people have been trying in north america
for 20 years with limited success
the fruits of that labor are finally
showing up good job tofu good job
do you think the truffle world is about
to change dramatically in the us
definitely
u.s has been behind the curve on
truffles
i think the energy in the truffle world
is coming to the u.s right now
even though he's been trying to grow for
more than a decade curion is still not
quite ready to sell
if you want real truffles direct right
now
not the synthetic chemical spray that's
often added to things like truffle fries
you need to go to places like sabatino
advertised as the largest truffle
distributor in the world the truffles
first arrived from europe here in
connecticut what's taking place here
right now so here essentially so we got
this all batch and we're going through a
sorting
process where we saw them by size
vincent johnson is part of an operation
that's been family run since 1911. when
you're trying to tell if it's a good
truffle
what what are you doing so you're
looking you're looking for a firm
product you don't need you don't want
something that's too soft that gives in
when it gives in a bit too much that
means it's probably overripe this one is
very fresh you can tell it's super firm
how much are all these truffles worth
right here
this is about just shy of 80 000 worth
retail value prices for the best white
truffles reach thousands of dollars a
pound
and are used at places like zuma in new
york city
my kind of christmas eh i know christmas
came early where wagyu tataki with ponzu
is finished with black winter truffle
chittoru tartare with caviar is topped
with white truffle
and a rice dessert with banana and
truffle honey features chocolate and
white truffles truffles are thought of
as a very high-end
luxury thing are they
they are in that they're very expensive
and
you tend to find them in really high-end
restaurants
but i don't think they have to be
jacobson says you don't need much to
make a great meal just a few grams and
if you're determined to find them you
don't have to pay a hundred dollars for
a plate of pasta at a fancy restaurant
for example yeah let's make breakfast
the decadent but easy earth-to-table
meal that curion and jacobson whipped up
for us on the farm great thing about
truffles is
they couldn't be easier to use at home
because you really just want to hit your
warm food with them at the last minute
basically with truffles as we witnessed
a little bit goes a long way bon appetit
wow
and with just a touch more time
nature's most amazing smell could be
lighting up your senses
sooner than you think
am i going to be eating truffles on my
burger
in 20 years instead of ketchup
i hope you're going to be eating
truffles on your burger in two years but
20 years yeah i'm pretty sure that uh
maybe with the ketchup yeah i guess you
can do them together yeah pretty good
actually
there you go and this morning thanks to
sabatino who sent these gorgeous
blasts just smell that
they're they're they're it's amazing
there's a little
kind of like you're not used to this
it's very difficult how did you describe
it in the piece yeah i i said gross but
great right throw sounds like a tough
word but it's like some people just it's
very it's earthy it's um so sabatino
sent over some gorgeous black and winter
truffles
and white winter truffles so we have
burgers we have ketchup
yeah a little bit of a high-low
combination about taking this bite here
we go here we go
it's good it's good
oh my gosh do you like it mm-hmm yeah
all right well i have to take these now
yeah